tonight we'll be doing some thinking
about
discerning uh
particularly in this area of
understanding um
evil in the context of pathological
narcissism as you remember from
my first presentation i said that
one of the contributions of scott peck
has been to
talk about the way in which
pathological narcissism is related to
what we know in theological reflections
as evil i also said to you that i think
it's important for us to
uh be very clear that the way in which
he has divided this
uh you know the the spectrum of
personality issues and problems
uh is problematic uh in which he has
all of the uh personality disorders etc
etc etc
are in difficulties neurotic and so
forth
and then on one uh in one group of
people who are
very ill he has decided to call those
people evil
the ones that have extremely severe
narcissistic pathology i
i said to you that i think that is
really
misleading and it misses
the way in which uh all of us
have to some degree some difficulties
in terms of pathological narcissism
uh i do a lot of teaching on this type
of area
in my teaching at chicago theological
seminary one course that i've been
teaching a long time
is a course called psychopathology and
theological perspective
i always use uh scott tech's people of
the lie as a bad example
of how to do this uh but and what i
what i suggest and here again we've got
30 or more hours of material which we're
going to go
over very fast
what i do is to take the diagnostic and
statistical manual
of the american psychiatric association
and i have my students
take a syndrome and do a theological
analysis of that syndrome
looking for the particular way in which
they might understand
each syndrome to reflect what we might
call in some way the demonic
or evil or pathological narcissism in
some form
uh it's it's uh very clear
that when you understand the way in
which narcissistic wounding
is an important part in the difficulties
of human beings
and that you that you get to the point
that you can see how
everything from obsessive compulsive or
compulsive personality disorders
to uh to histrionic personality
disorders right across the board you can
if you understand enough about
about narcissistic pathology you can see
the way
in which that syndrome also reflects
this wounding
and this difficulty or we might say uh
it
manifests evil in this way so in other
words
rather than making a handful of very
troubled people
carry the brunt of being evil
it's kind of like more like what we
might say about sin you don't ask
are you a sinner you ask how am i a
sinner
and you try to get some sense about how
your life has been compromised in some
way by
the forces of uh of evil or the demonic
and the context of this lecture tonight
i just wanted to start out by saying
that i was particularly appreciative of
of uh the way in which john uh
doorly characterized
spirituality the nature of spirituality
uh
and particularly his emphasis on
the importance of spirituality and
accessing
the forces of life accessing the
energies
of life so that life might be lived
uh with with joy and be lived with
fullness
because that is precisely the kind of
area
we get into when we examine
what narcissistic pathology is really
like
and what i'd like to do tonight is to
talk with you
about pathological narcissism
how what uh give you some of the
understanding of uh
uh how wounding and uh in one's
narcissism
uh happens uh some of the marks of that
uh some of the current theories about
how that is treated
and i'd like to relate it then to uh
some of the things that i think that
jungian psychology
offers us in terms of understanding the
the varieties of expression
that this kind of wounding can take and
so when we speak of discerning
the way in which pathological narcissism
or the expression of
evil and psychological forms
affects us we will take a look at the
different ways which it can be
understood to
afflict us and the way in which jungian
psychology helps us understand that
let me start out by
having us reflect a little bit
on the mythology of
satan uh
to get us you know we're doing a
psychological reflection on evil now
and you know i recommended that you look
at those books by jeffrey burton russell
on uh
the history of satan and they have a
number here in the uh
in the bookstore um
one of the interesting things that uh
becomes clear from jeffrey burton
russell's research
is that the way in which satan is talked
about in mythology
and in history makes them sound like
someone that we would talk about today
as a person with
a with a severe narcissistic personality
disorder
uh some of the things that are
emphasized about
satan in some of the legends
are that satan is very envious
of the place that god
holds and that
he feels that his beauty
is not being seen and appreciated
and one of the stories has him waiting
until god leaves the room
and going up and sitting down on god's
throne and having his
uh particular group of
of angels this is before they leave you
know
have this particular group of angels
come around and see how he looks
sitting on the throne and he says
something to the effect of i think my
beauty
uh is even more outstanding than that of
god
and uh and they all agree
uh and one of the stories that jeffrey
bretton russell
tells is uh the
chagrin and shame when
god walks back in the room and confronts
him about this
it's very interesting that this idea
of satan as being someone who wants to
be
seen and wants to be celebrated and
wants to be noticed and wants to be seen
as beautiful
is a theme which is repeated
throughout a lot of mythology about
satan
and one of the reasons why people think
that
satan represents a good that needs to be
integrated is that
satan in some ways seems to represent
our exhibitionistic self
the part that wants to have a little
glory
you know you've heard of sola deo gloria
you know uh
to god alone be the glory
well the the picture of satan is that he
can say
well why not a little bit for me why not
a little glory for me uh
and when we get into a look at
narcissistic development in a moment
you will see why this image of satan is
somebody who is longing
to be seen longing to be noticed
longing to have just a little bit of
that glory or what you and i glory is a
word that
somehow parallels what we might call
luminosity
uh you know when we speak of archetypal
energies and we speak of numenosity that
special magical
uh energy that uh the contact with the
archetypal self gives us
it gives you a little sense of glory you
shine a little bit like gold
or like diamonds and so
as we look at narcissistic development
we will see that it's a very normal
thing
for a person to need to develop
a capacity to accept
being seen to accept being celebrated to
accept their own drive toward
exhibitionism
and when we get into difficulties in our
development
on the north what is known as the
narcissistic line of development
we get to where we have problems about
this
we might say we have satan's problems
about this and so what i'd like to start
with tonight
is talking to you a little bit about
some of the current
understanding of uh
narcissistic development what we mean by
that in psychoanalysis today and how
that differs from what it used to be
uh thought about and then talk a little
bit about
the current understanding of what is
needed to heal
uh difficulties with narcissistic
development so that we can get some
sense
about the geography that we're operating
in here in the psyche so let me start
a little bit about what we know today
about narcissistic development
you know in the history of the church
the idea that you might be narcissistic
was considered sort of like
egocentrism and was to be a bad thing
that is to say this is where we got our
idea that that
being selfless was good
and the idea that you really should be
humble by which you would mean
you would not want to put yourself
forward
you would not want to toot your own horn
so to speak
you would not want to to
show yourself as being too enthusiastic
about yourself
that would not be humble you see
uh in current theory however
uh and the feminists have picked up on
this quite a lot
uh in current theory
narcissism is not seen to be a negative
thing in itself
at all that is to say they have
developed an idea that there is such a
thing as
healthy narcissism in other words we
need to make a distinction between
healthy narcissism
and pathological narcissism
now healthy narcissism
is something that takes a lot of work to
develop
in the psyche the the school of thought
that i want to recommend to you to look
at
is the school of heinz cohen i've
mentioned it to you before
heinz kohut and the name of this school
of thought is
self psychology
in kohut's work it is emphasized
that the child comes into the world
with a grandiosity
which is normal and natural
and this grandiosity is a healthy
grandiosity for the infant
and what it needs is to be seen by the
parents
it needs to be welcomed by the parents
reunions would talk about this somewhere
in the neighborhood of the archetype of
the divine child
that is to say that when the child comes
into the world
what it needs is to be seen and admired
and adored
and the technical word is mirrored
that the child needs to be mirrored it
needs to be seen
and all eyes need to be on it
if there needs to be no rejection
of its little claim to being a wonderful
little god
and the task of the adults in its
environment are to
provide that adoration you can think
it's almost like a crash theme
you know everybody gathers around what
you're supposed to do is you bring the
sheep in the goats
and the camels and everybody
adores the child and this is normal see
this is supposed to happen according to
kohut
and as the child develops it is very
important for the parents to
provide this kind of excited
enthusiastic blessing eye
so that when the child is feeling
wonderful
the child will be met by an attuned
response which will say yeah you are
pretty wonderful aren't you
it's like one little boy that uh
that uh was a neighbor of mine one time
he was in visiting he and his dad were
investing with me
and he came in and he said dad he
interrupted his dad he said
dad i really feel good today
yeah yeah he said i feel so good
that i think that i can have a bm so big
that it will go down the mississippi
river
and it will knock down all the bridges
all the way to the ocean
and uh and my friend said
wow
which was uh what the cohesions would
say that was a very attuned response
instead of saying get out of here you
know he said
wow you must really feel great today
yeah dad
let's see now
what happens is that optimally you know
i mean that's supposed to happen
optimally the parent is supposed to be
attuned and in touch and and notice this
and and give the the gleam in the eye
to that divine child in that little
child and according to the kohushan
theory
if the parents do that
then the child will be able to accept
this wonderfulness and
when he falls down or stubs his toe or
something doesn't work quite right
and he is upset the parent because the
parent is attuned
will pick them up restore the sense of
self
and gradually the child will integrate
that wonderfulness that that godlike
wonderfulness
into a sense of self-esteem a nice
normal
sense of self-esteem that if the parent
works with the child as
they come down from this great throne of
godness
and the parent doesn't let the child be
unduly traumatized
uh in the encounter with life
that gradually that that that god
claim will gradually be here's the
technical word
transmuted and internalized and what
that simply means is that gradually that
child
will increase in self-esteem
increase increasingly have a sense of
self
in the face of the challenges of
life experiences and whenever
disappointments come
the sense of self will be so strong that
the person the child will not the child
and later adult will not get depressed
too easily
not not become enraged too easily
but will be able to handle the
difficulties of life
without losing a sense of self and that
it's a gradual process they they talk
about here's another technical word
and you parents uh
you've done this millions of times but
they talk about micro structuralization
and all by that that means that that
every time he stops his toe you comfort
and every time he says look how
wonderful i am they're seen
and you hope that they're seen well
enough
and that there's enough parental
enthusiasm and enough parental
celebration
i call it parental blessing so that that
child
gradually comes down off of the god
claim
into the human realm with a healthy
sense of self-esteem
now that's the way it's supposed to
happen
see but the problem is
that a lot of the time uh the person
or persons who are supposed to be there
paying attention are what
distracted busy tired discouraged
preoccupied drunk
whatever now co-ed says you know
a child doesn't have to have this
perfect mirroring this this good
mirroring if there's somebody in the
environment
that the child can idealize with and
snuggle up to
that the child can can see is wonderful
so in other words if you can either see
the child is wonderful or you can be
adequate enough for the child to see you
as wonderful
and let the child come up and be close
to you and share in your wonderfulness
so kohut says you can the child can get
us enough sense of
being good either by being
mirrored adequately or by you
being capable of being admired
well you know dad may be capable of
being admired
but he may not be there he may be gone
or dad may be abusive
if that is abusive it ruins the child's
ability to admire that
so in other words there are things that
happen
in the life of early childhood that keep
this healthy sense of wonderfulness from
developing and gradually
coming down to human size
now what happens
if the child either
is not mirrored enough that is
if if the child does not get enough
attuned careful attention in celebration
or there isn't somebody in the
environment for the child to admire
and snuggle up to does this mean that
this grandiosity that the child comes
into the world with
goes away not according to kohut
according to kohut and the self
psychologist
the grandiosity remains
present but get this in its primitive
forms you get that
now stay with that a minute and i want
you to think about it because it's
important for understanding this stuff
the child has this normal god claim
i'm just a little wonderful package of
joy see
and it's natural normal healthy
needs to be met with this welcoming
crash you know
if it is that stuff transforms gradually
and the child comes down off the throne
to join the human race
with healthy self-esteem
if it doesn't happen and there's no one
to idealize and merge with
adequately then the path the the
infantile grandiosity
does not go away
it stays primitive
what happens to it then well various
things can happen to it which is what
we want to talk about tonight what
happens to it
is that it remains the grandiose
self-organization
in the psyche or sometimes called the
grandiose exhibitionistic
self-organization
it remains an entity in the psyche it is
not
transformed it remains
loaded with numerous energy
powerful energy powerful claims
with some persons
who we call technically narcissistic
personality disorders
this luminous powerful grandiose
self-organization
takes over the conscious ego most of the
time
this is the diagnostic and statistical
manuals
category called the narcissistic
personality disorder
this is a person that acts as if they
think
either they're god's gift to the world
or their god
giving a gift to the world
it is a person who believes that you
exist
to serve his or her
whims it is a person
who makes all sorts of claims on others
without feeling any need to reciprocate
it is a person with a compulsive need to
be adored
uncritically uncritically
now this is the case now stay with me on
this if this is the case when that
grandiose self organization has not been
transformed it has remained primitive
and in this person it stays in control
of the ego
of the person but that's only one
way that this works
it also works another way
it can remain intensely present
but because of the parental environments
not being
welcoming to it it is split off from
consciousness
in other words just because you don't
think you're god's gift to the world
consciously it does not mean
you do not have this grandiose
exhibitionistic self-organization
rattling around in there in your psyche
what other forms can it take
well one form that it takes
is chronic depression
in a first that is to say the person is
not aware
at all of having any
sense of godlike claims
or feeling godlike
what you do notice however
is that the individual feels
himself or herself to be the object
of perfectionistic attacks
in their own thoughts you see
whatever they do may they may say
this is not good enough
i shouldn't be here i am unworthy
every time they have a a creative
project to do
they may start it and tear it up why
not because the ego
really feels this but because behind the
ego's consciousness
the grandiose self-organization in this
primitive god-like way
is attacking every effort
of the human ego
and there are many many other forms of
this takes in other words the important
thing to get
is that when the child has not been
helped to come down from the high chair
this organization remains according to
the self-psychologist and we'll get to
the jungian view of this a little bit
but this organization remains intact it
either possesses the ego
in which case you have the narcissistic
personality disorder
or it remains out of the ego's
consciousness
and influences the personality and life
experience of the person from so to
speak behind
the scenes and what i would like us
to think together a little bit about is
is um
some of the ways in which this manifests
this especially the one that's behind
the scenes see
how does this manifest well it manifests
in a number of ways
i have mentioned depression chronic
depression
another way it manifests itself is in
chronic powerful compulsive
envy of other people
in other words if you find yourself
having a lot of struggles with the
problem of envying other people
this is one expression of this grandiose
self-organization
within the psyche not being accessible
to your conscious mind
but creating in you
envy attacks on other people what an
effect we're doing
is we project the great self out there
on others
and envy as if we don't have connection
with it
in other words if we don't have
connection with our own grandiosity we
do not have self-esteem
we don't have connection with our own
grandiosity we feel like we are nothing
and that makes everyone else around us
look as if they have the good and we do
not
we can't get to it
there is a
another important group of behaviors
that we normally do not associate
with this pathological narcissism
but which also manifests the presence
near the ego of this
grandiose self organization
and that is the the behaviors that we
know as compulsive behaviors
in other words according to the point of
view of self-psychology
all addictive behaviors are an
expression
of the energy the
the grandiose energies coming off of
this grandiose self-organization and the
individual ego or self-structure of the
individual not being able to integrate
this the compulsive behaviors are in
effect
the psyches struggle
you might even say it or i might even
say attempts to ritualize
attempts to come up with rituals to
contain
this enormous god energy in the psyche
to try to keep it under control in some
way
in other words compulsive behaviors
are equally manifestations of this
pathological infantile grandiosity
it's very important to see in this case
that you cannot in any simplistic way
moralize or blame this individual
for the struggle that they're in can you
see that
this is not their fault they cannot be
blamed for this
at all the compulsive behaviors that
they engage in whether they're like me
and they tend to be a workaholic
or whether they have eating disorders
or whether they have some form of
addictive compulsive behavior
according to this self psychology this
is all
manifestation of a struggle with an
unconscious grandiose self organization
which is not
being adequately related to by the
individual ego or conscious mind
it's very important yes codependency
yes it would now we need to get
we need to get a little sense
i'd like for you to to think about this
in the context of dr of trying to become
much more aware of certain types of
behaviors that we all
that is to say here is the assumption
that i want you to entertain
tonight i want you to entertain the
assumption that all of us had less than
perfect childhoods
see right
and i want you to entertain the
possibility that we didn't have enough
camels and sheep standing around and
admiring us
at various times and it's just possible
that in every one of us in this room
there remains
some rather primitive aspects of this
childhood grandiosity still around
now if it is there will be little signs
of it
and i'd like to take just a little bit
time right now for us to work together
on what some little clues may be
that you may notice
well let's start
the self psychologists are really
wonderful in in being empathic to people
struggle with their grandiosity and what
i love about the way they do this they
are not moralistic about this they don't
moralize at people about their struggle
with their child
their infantile grandiosity their
extreme their their
their they are capable of being a good
example for us christians
on this issue there are a lot of these
little signs
one let's just go through a list i'm
going to give you a list of marks of
recognizing this residual
untransformed the way they talk about it
we'll talk
jungian about it in a minute but they
talk about untransformed untransmuted
primitive grandiosity that
that remains uh influencing you
depreciation tendencies
that is if you notice yourself spending
a lot of energy depreciating yourself
or other people it's a dead giveaway
now people normally think that that's
that is my eye that's that's robert
criticizing robert
according to the self psychologist
when robert says to robert
oh you're never going to amount to
anything
that's not the true self of robert
speaking to robert
according to the self psychologist that
is a
voice coming off of the grandiosity
the grandiose step organization in
effect has a voice in my psyche
and it says to me
and you know conceivably
that was a lousy book that you published
or you should have published two books
10 books
100 books they all should have been
better
you notice that split infinities see
whatever you put put your own version of
this one of the things i like to do with
groups of people
is to have them write down these
thoughts that they have about themselves
i will never blank or you know
you're never going to ever learn so and
so you know
you think fill in the blank with your
own thoughts according to self
psychology these things are normally
coming off of the grandiose staff
organization
the punitive self-rejecting
discouraging thoughts are normally
coming off of that so anytime you notice
depreciation
of self or others if there's a lot of
energy going into depreciating other
people
it's probably coming off of a primitive
organization of the grandiosity
why do you say that because if you've
got
your grandiosity in harness according to
the self-psychologist
you're expending it in creation you're
doing something useful with it
see it's going into productivity
you don't have time to be criticizing
other people
you're too busy doing something useful
so that's one form
we've talked about eating disorders if
you have any problem with eating
disorders overeating
or or bulimic kinds of patterns
this would be understood by
self-psychologists
as a direct expression of the struggle
that you are have
dealing with this thing in your psyche
that has not been
digested in effect in other words when
you see someone
struggling with a diet
you have right before you there a person
that's struggling
with the appetite of a giant within
see it's not the true self of that
individual
that that's that's that hungry all the
time
see it's the grandiose self organization
because see the grandiose self
organization within is insatiable
you can't feed it enough you can't beat
it enough food
you can't feed it enough booze you can't
feed it enough drugs
you can't give it enough sex so behind
all the compulsive behaviors
the self-psychologists see see
that organization
insomnia the self-psychologists see
sleep difficulties as often directly
related
to this grandiose organization and it
can be related
in this way there are a number of things
that happen to you when this thing
is when the grandiose self organization
within is not
adequately transformed and integrated
it tends to over stimulate you
now think about this it tends when
you're in touch with it it tends to over
stimulate you insomnia the self
psychologist
would say is a mark of the fact that
that the
grandiose self organization is is
getting you revved up too much
and you have not learned ways to
calm yourself and to soothe yourself
see because this thing is too big it's
like i like to say to people they're
trying to understand this
it's like a big excited saint bernard
that smells the food and he starts
lunging against the door
and so what you've got to do is try to
find some way to calm him down
see and a lot of people drink too much
at night
because they're so over stimulated
they can't get down they can't calm down
so they can go to sleep a lot of people
this country is
is full of valium junkies uh
people are taking enormous amounts of
valium
to cope with their unintegrated
grandiose step organization see
okay but there are other ways in which
this thing
manifests besides overstimulation now
you can think of the various ways in
which you may manifest
types of overstimulation of this thing
within
but there's another thing that we see
according to the self-psychologist and
that is called
defending against grandiosity
now what forms does that take
for example a person with extremely low
self-esteem
who does not feel that he or she is very
important often the self psychologist
will say that person
is defending desperately against the
presence
of the grandiosity why
because there is a fear in the psyche
that if they let themselves know
anything about themselves being good
or okay this thing would roll in and
take over
in other words according to the self
psychologist there is a fear of
psychosis
when you see someone who is very meek
and self-effacing
i have no self-esteem don't say anything
good about me
don't compliment me
for god's sake don't notice me according
to the self-psychologist that's very
often a person not a person who has no
grandiosity within
but that's a person who's hold against
it
is so tenuous that if you pay too much
attention to them they begin to have
enormous anxiety peaks
they start having enormous anxiety
states
you may you may have noticed that some
people you will try to complement
and they will push it away they do not
want even they don't not want to hear it
at all
according to self psychology these would
be persons who have enormous struggle
with this grandiose self organization
and you are actually
threatening the structural integrity of
their self by complimenting them
you see this now this has you can
imagine this has
enormous significance for spiritual
direction
because if you have such a person you're
working with or you're trying to help
and you are so eager
to get them feeling better about
themselves
and so you start trying to say positive
things about them you start trying to
build them up
you start trying to really uh give them
good experiences that
that will make them not feel so bad
and if you do not have some sense of the
dynamics of this
you may be causing them enormous
peaking in their anxiety states because
they cannot
stand you feeling good about them
one of the things that you as a
spiritual director or a helping person
once you understand this type of thing
you will know that
you must be careful about
overstimulating
this grandiosity until the person can
gain
gradually greater and greater a sense of
themself
their their own self-structure so they
can stand it
now this is interesting in the light of
our discussion about
doing something with satan that is to
say
the redemption of that element if that's
an element in the psyche
that exhibitionistic part can't be fast
you've got to be you've got to let that
capacity to be
seen to be seen as beautiful grow very
slowly
it can't be fast or it threatens the
person with the disintegration of their
self structure
now this helps us to understand
a lot of behaviors which are puzzling to
us
a lot of creative personalities you may
have noticed
self-destruct when they get successful
you may have noticed successful
actors successful artists
successful musicians who either commit
suicide
or drink themselves to death or die
young with drug overdoses
according to the self psychologist this
happens
when people get too much attention
the success overstimulates them
the grandiose self organization begins
to threaten
the integrity of their self
and they start to medicate it or they
start to act out
which gets us to another form of
expression
of this difficulty
it is the concept that you've heard many
times possibly acting out
when we say someone is acting out what
do we mean
a lot of bizarre anti-social behaviors
for one thing
uh violent behaviors it often includes
some sort of
relatively bizarre uh interpersonal
behaviors
often including violence or bizarre
sexual behaviors
or other kinds of
acting out conflicts that can't be
understood
in terms of the person's own grasp of
themselves
but according to the self-psychologist
people act
out when they cannot stand the pressure
of the grandiose self organization
anymore give you an example
if someone is struggling with a drug
addiction
and they are getting a handle on it and
they're being able to
function fairly well if
there is a disturbance in their
relationships
this will often lead to the grandiose
self-organization
becoming destabilizing again for them
and this is the time according to the
self psychologist
that the individual will go back for
more drugs
if you're working from this point of
view with an alcoholic
the alcoholic will not fall off the
wagon
until there is something that causes a
disturbance
which causes the grandiose
self-organization again to
destabilize the ego or what they call
the self-structure of the individual
so the the
difficulty takes many forms uh the ones
that you and i see the most
are the ones that we've talked about
intense envy
depressive states uh
heightened anxiety insomnia compulsive
behavior
uh what we know as manic phases
sleeplessness
that sort of thing according to the self
psychologist
the the integrity of the human ego
of the person because the grandiosity
was never
integrated and built up into self-esteem
and self-structure
the person is very very subject to
splitting behaviors of all kinds
and often your so-called multiple
personalities
will be individuals for whom the
grandiose self organization is so
powerful that they cannot maintain
the structural and integrity of oneself
and we'll see in a moment when we turn
to the jungian way of thinking about
this
the way in which from a jungian point of
view we split into archetypal
configurations at these times
that is to say when the grandiose
self-organization is still primitive and
raw
uh we will tend to become archetypes not
persons
any self-soothing
kinds of compulsive rituals in some way
that we might do there are people that
that can't do anything but come home and
read at night
they sit there and read other people
can't read
because of the overstimulation one of
the things that we do
in self-psychological treatment of
persons is to help them recognize
when their grandiosity is becoming
overwhelming
see you begin to help the person
tell when they're getting to the point
that they're about to come apart
let me just say a word about their view
of how this is healed the the
self-psychologist view
of how this is healed very simply
the person gets into therapy with a with
an analyst who understands this business
the analyst tries to provide for the
individual
a mirroring uh of this grandiosity
an attunement to the grandiosity a
non-attack on it
you try to welcome the awareness of this
grandiosity into the consulting room
it's very interesting the the therapist
tries to help the person get in touch
with an awareness of these grandiose
feelings
in other words it's not good for them to
stay out of awareness
because if they're out of awareness you
can't do much about them
so the therapy proceeds in trying to
help the individual
become more aware of this grandiosity
and of finding ways to be more accepting
of it
and to be able to deal with it in
constructive ways
to get the energy i get this it sounds
familiar to unions doesn't it
there is energy in that grandiosity
there is energy for life this is what i
was thinking about when john was talking
about
the energy for life there is energy
for living in that grandiose self
organization
and because of the failures in parenting
that person has never been able to plug
in
to that grandiosity in an adequate way
and to have that grandiosity
fuel their life with zest
and vitality and energy toward actual
human endeavors toward realizable human
ambitions
and that sort of thing and so what the
self psychology therapy tries to
accomplish is helping the individual
not to feel bad about their grandiosity
that's not the idea at all it's really
kind of amusing
you try to help the person feel good
about their grandiose fantasies
yes yes one particular example that i
thought was very interesting
after a long time in therapy
with a self-psychologist this one woman
who was 52
finally felt accepted enough and
mirrored enough
to bring out her fantasy
her fantasy was that she wanted to be a
rock star
52 she wants to be a janis joplin
now it took her a long time to get to
where she could admit this
to the therapist and so
what their therapy attempted to do was
to have her
to stop feeling so much shame
about that fantasy now think about the
batman movie and all that stuff in this
light
these all these hidden all these hidden
away superheroes you know
batman superman
[Music]
but to help her feel good about her
fantasy about wanting to be a rock star
and what she started to do is figure out
ways that she can bring some of the
energies off of that janice joplin
into the workplace so she went to work
and gradually she announced to her
co-workers lookout now
i'm coming down here in a new way
in other words she began to bring in a
lot more of her grandiose
exhibitionistic energy
into her personality and expressing it
at work and you know the interesting
thing
is people usually enjoy you a lot more
if you're a little bit in touch with
your grandiosity
if you're not in touch with it you're
kind of boring see
so the idea is to help individuals plug
into that not feel shame about it but to
plug into that
and to learn to do now what they didn't
learn to do as a child
learn to feel okay about this grandiose
fantasy and to gradually try to find
ways to embody this
now let's let's turn to look at
a way a jungian way of thinking about
this very same business
now again we talked a little bit about
the importance of the relationship
between the ego
and the archetypal self
and we talk about how jungians uh
edinger
in particular has helped us talk about
the need for the formation of the ego
south axis now you should be able to
think
about what a jungian would say about
some of the things we've been talking
about
that is to say the archetypal self
carries
that grandiose energy
that we've been talking about you see
the the archetypal self like the
grandiose self organization according to
the uh
south psychologist is full of fuel
but you can get in trouble with the
archetypal self
just as you can get in trouble with the
grandiose self organization
see you can either be
too close to it in the sense of
you can become identified with it like
the narcissistic personality disorder
you could say that the narcissistic
personality disorder is identified with
it
or you can be in terms of your ego
out of touch with it consciously
now what we ought to be able to see
however is just because the
ego does not
know it to itself to be in touch with
the archetypal self it doesn't mean it
isn't
in other words when you're not plugged
in adequately to your
archetypal self it doesn't mean that
your archetypal self is not in there
what is going on usually
the archetypal self is in your shadow
much more
the archetypal energies are in your
shadow and you will normally project
those things
you will either project them onto
someone else or you will act them out
in some way unconsciously
uh we can talk about manic depression
as an individual who sometimes will get
too much of a dose of archetypal energy
and then oscillate away and get too
little of it
accessible to the ego
very similar to the way the
psychoanalytic self
psychologists talk about the energies
of the grandiosity but one of the things
that i think is important for us to see
about the contribution of jungian
thought
is that from the jungian point of view
you can see that the
the human personality is very very
creative about ways of being
grandiose you can be grandiose in a lot
of different ways
not just one you don't just have the
narcissistic personality disorder if you
think about this miyunian point of view
you can be grandiose
and be acting out in any one of a number
of configurations and what i want to do
with you before we
stop and discuss i want us to go through
some of the different configurations in
which
the infantile grandiosity you might say
can be expressed
in different archetypal figurations
configurations in different psyches
and let's go through them now and uh
and then we will discuss all this stuff
what they talk about is the narcissistic
personality disorder the one we talked
about about the person that thinks
they're god's gift to the world
is in my view an example of an
individual who
is experiencing an archetypal inflation
in the mode of the king or the queen
it's very interesting to think about
the narcissistic personality disorder as
sort of a boy king
sitting on his high chair expecting
everybody to adore him
expecting everybody to mirror him
expecting everybody to bless him
for himself to become the center of the
world
uh the uh the narcissistic personality
disorder
is said to be incapable of love
and uh in this case you would say that
the individual expects the energies to
come toward him
not to go out he's not to be giving out
yes
father had a son who had children and he
could no longer get all the attention
and then just these symptoms showed up
at that
stage
normally he's saying that he's observed
this in a case that he's that he's
worked with
uh if the individual
has been pam you know you can get to be
a narcissistic personality disorder
and kind of think you're the boy king or
the boy the girl queen in a lot of ways
you can be pampered see pampering will
do it
because one of the important things that
uh these people
uh that work with us talk about is that
you have to be let down from your little
high chair thrones
gradually if they knock you off your
high chair thrown by hitting you and
beating you up as a child
it doesn't it doesn't transform this
stuff
it doesn't integrate its self-esteem you
have to be let down gradually see
and uh when they don't let you down
gradually
uh and they uh knock you down
you can continue to be this type of
personality
or if you are so wonderful to your
parents that they
never let you think you're anything but
a little god
then you haven't learned from your
parents that you're not a little god
you haven't learned it in incremental
doses so if you've been extremely
pampered by a doting parent
you have had that grandiosity not
gradually transformed
into self-esteem it has remained raw
you're still
a little god on the high chair or
goddess on the high chair
so this is the one that they know most
about in terms of the literature
you see this this form of the
narcissistic personality disorder
most clearly but
it can also be expressed if the
warrior archetypal pattern is loaded
with archetypal energy
and in that case it doesn't come out
as a little lord fought leroy on his
high chair
how would you suggest that an inflated
warrior
the grandiosity coming out in the form
of the warrior would express itself
like rambling violence
the violent personality who is go who
goes into rages a lot
and who acts out violently a lot
uh you see the the boy warrior
or the girl warrior sometimes i've
helped i've worked with a number of
people who've been battered by their
wives
he says uh couldn't that also be people
who get fanatical about
causes and that would be absolutely an
expression of that
uh you can talk about the way in which
the the
messianic warrior comes out in this
uh when a person gets into some
particular
uh social movement or social cause and
it takes the one of the interesting
things about it you can always tell when
it's an inflation
because it's so one-sided in other words
that consumes the individual's life
and this is one of the things another
form it takes
that's not as bizarre as that the one
i'm more subject to
is workaholism see the
obsessive-compulsive personality
is in many ways just as inflated as the
narcissistic personality disorder
it's just that the obsessive compulsive
the in the obsessive compulsive it's
going into the warrior configuration
see the warrior is into working
carrying out the mission and nothing is
important but the mission
the family is not important see
feelings are not important the fam
the children are not important nothing
is important except the mission
when you see people that are into
professional uh careers
uh to the exclusion of all relationships
you see an inflation what i would
consider a grandiose
pathologically infantile inflation in
the warrior configuration
this is a very common one among
uh professionals
particularly among the you know yuppies
today
i mean you'll see a lot of them who get
totally fixated upon this
and somehow don't understand what's
happening when they cannot get
shifting any gears into building a
family for example
there seems to be no energy for having a
family life
uh and no energy for any kind of
intensive committed relationships
now what about
a grandiose inflation
in the magician or the priest or
priestess
how would that manifest itself
anybody take a stab at it
could be a pseudo messiah although
messiahs tend to be more activists they
tend to be more kind of
warrior kings but uh
there are some aspect the the the
religious
knower the one who has the religious
message would be an example of that i
think that may be what you're getting at
other other examples of that yes
you could go
see when you're inflated when you're
inflated in a in a grandiose way in
in the magician you want to know
everything
see and you don't want to do
anything
see you want to know everything before
you do anything
and this is like you know you see this a
lot in us professors
because you know if there's any kind of
crisis going on in society or anything
you know somebody gets hit by a car
we will have a commission to study it
we won't call an ambulance
we'll study it there's something can be
learned by this
you know it's like it's like what we do
in chicago we got all these homeless
people you know
we gotta we got people in terrible
straits
but my academic colleagues we're into
studying it
uh and it's omega's inflation that's one
form it takes what are some other forms
that omega's inflation will take back
here
when the therapist or counselor gets
into a power trip
with the patient and and and
is locked into the counselor's own
agenda rather than being
empathic with the person they're working
with
this is one that the self psychologists
talk about a lot
that is to say
just because you think you know what the
the patient feels
doesn't mean you do and they
they put a great deal event of emphasis
on empathy
trying to feel your way into the to the
actual states feeling states of the
individual
if you're really into a power trip as a
therapist
uh in this magus inflation
you won't do that but there are other
things that you
tell me more about therapists here in
this this is a this is one that we
therapists major in
we therapists really get inflated in the
magician thing a lot
what are some other expressions of that
schizoid absolutely that is to say that
that if you're locked into this in an
inflation you may not look at all
arrogant
to somebody looking at you
but if you are if you are grandiose
in the magician form you will pull out
of relationships
emotionally that's what he means by
schizoid
you will not be experiencing much
energy in your feeling function
with individuals uh you will get
you you will get more into that knowing
business you see
others yes
super mom or super dad i think super mom
and super dad more more come in this in
this one
uh the person who is locked into
mothering and can't do anything but
mother
oh i see i see having all the answers
anybody that anybody that is into just
always having all the answers has got a
lot of this there's no question about it
but i'm thinking when you've got
somebody that if it moves they mother it
you know they mother the husband they
mother the kids they mother the car
you know they're in this one
and of course with the warrior if it
moves they fight it
we won't talk about this one yet
oh yes let's do
now let's get to the inflated the
grandiose lover
what are some of the forms that this
takes when the grandio okay promiscuity
is one
and that's the one we talked about uh
the other day in terms
so many men or women in so little time
uh
there's never enough opportunities
to engage in seduction
or sexual activity that's one but there
are other expressions of grandiosity
in the lover what are some of the other
expressions of the pathological
grandiosity
as it manifests in this configuration
never enough relationships uh
that's kind of a form of promiscuity
there are a lot of people who you know
they they develop a lot of
of intimate relationships and
they're very they're very quick to tell
you that that they're not genital
relationships
but i mean they're very faithful to
their spouse
it's just that they have all of these
intimate relationships
all over the country see and they get
very upset when the spouse is
jealous uh
this this constant seeking out new
exciting
relationship this is aphrodite this is
an expression of the aphrodite
energy think about you read gene
bowling's book on aphrodite
see aphrodite really loves every man she
sees
she really loves them just that's when
another one comes along he's beautiful
too and she loves him
she just she just sees all this beauty
but what are some other expressions of
inflation or grandiosity in the lover
configuration yes
that would be he says the what about the
sexual abuse of clients or patients i
would think that that could be argued to
be
an expression of this coming blasting
through the shadow side of the therapist
a lot of therapists you know don't tend
to their personal lives enough
in fact uh some of the people that have
written about therapy say that they the
therapists tend to be voice
and they don't spend enough time
developing their personal life
and therefore this side of their
personality is not
getting enough energy normally
consciously
and so it's in the shadow and so often
the the lover will come blasting through
uh with these uh with these grandiose
energies
and uh one of the interesting things
about there was a very prominent uh
therapist who who was acting out in the
way you're talking about
and the amazing thing was that when
confronted about it by his colleagues
he could not he couldn't understand what
they were upset about
see that's one of the one of the uh
expressions of grandiosity see when when
when confronted he couldn't he couldn't
what's wrong with you people
i'm you know i'm this is this is
important for these people you know i'm
helping them
see uh and it was a clearly a possession
state
so that would be a good example
codependence is a clear one
one of the things that that that i had
pointed out to me about this was that a
lot of the time you can see
the addictions as disorders in the lover
as a grandiosity in the lover
because the individual comes out and and
falls in love
with some substance or falls in love
with
really loves booze really
loves food and uh
there's a there's a lot of talk about
about uh
addictions as disorders of the upper
other examples yes
falling in love with love yes that is
this this energy is so powerful you see
it's numinous
it's sacred when it's expressed in this
when it's expressed in this form yes
right here
in this category don says with child
sexual abuse be in this category uh in
my
in my view i tend to see it there
because
a lot of people say you know a lot of
people say that there is no there's no
love or affection in child sexual abuse
i'm not sure they're right about that i
think maybe you see
the lover when it is in a grandiose form
grandiose state it's polymorphous
perverse
if it's a dominant if it's a big
domination thing it would be the warrior
to be the warrior
but uh but a lot of the time you see
this when one is in this state this is
the this is the part of the self that is
uh is uh capable of being sexual with
anything
you know persons places things
you name it
or the demanding of elaborate gifts
offering or or demanding i think it
would be more the offering
of of elaborate gifts
the uh the compulsive expression of
loving
uh the important thing to see and let's
just discuss this now a little bit more
the important thing to see is that
there's not one form
that a grandiosity will take the
grandiose energies the archetypal
press can be expressed in any of these
patterns
and so rather than just seeing it as as
a narcissistic personality disorder if
you take a jungian point of view
then you can see that when you're when
you're
mainlining these energies like this
they can come out in any of these ways
now let's do something a little
different before we stop
we've been emphasizing what happens when
you're mainlining when you're shooting
up this archetypal energy
and it comes out in one of the other
forms
what about when you're not getting
enough
of the archetypal energy in these
different
configurations remember when john was
talking about
spirituality is putting you in touch
with the energy for life
what happens when you don't get enough
energy
to light up these configurations
let's go through them again what would
you say what happens
to an individual how would you tell an
individual who was
out of touch with archetypal energy in
this one
give me an example well how so she says
mr milk toast how so
what uh how is that not getting energy
here
no okay she says not doing anything
being flat one of the things that uh
that you you could argue is that an
individual who has no power drive
probably has no no energy going into
this configuration of the king
no power drive no expression of attempt
to build
anything if an individual has no no
impetus to build anything at all
then this is not being fueled
by archetypal energy
child abandonment is very interesting
that is the individual simply
is not experiencing any of their king or
queen
circuits see i think this happens a lot
today
when the career takes all of the energy
or this takes all of the energy
and the children are left
yes
in other words dependency will often be
a manifestation
uh inability to stand up to some other
initiative will be an example if you
have a lot of king or queen energy it's
not easy to run over you
see you got you know you have your own
if you have a lot of king or queen
energy you've got
you you you're pretty centered one thing
about you
even if you have it in a pathological
form
it's awfully hard to run over you
okay what about what about not having
enough
of the archetypal energy going into the
warrior configuration
what will an individual be like yes
you're all very good tonight she says
passive aggressive behavior absolutely
right and if you've got somebody that's
passive aggressive
this is not being fueled enough with
archetypal energy
and one of the things you have to work
with i i gave a series of lectures on
the warrior archetype recently
and that was one of the points that i
made that there is so much passive
aggression around
i mean it's just like it drives you nuts
especially if you're if you're if you're
trying to be aggressive and you're in a
room full of passive aggressive people
a committee what else would you say
about that besides passive aggression
yeah laziness that is that what we would
call laziness if i
feel lazy you know laziness doesn't tell
you anything
it's just a kind of a description of
what you're not doing
but so so you say slaw so-called the the
sin of sloth would be an example
of just this not being fueled in other
words if this is being
fueled you won't
have a feeling of aimlessness
because the warrior part of you will
find the mission
and if you don't have a sense of mission
this is not being fueled see anything
else you can see there
apathy would be another example
depression can often come under that uh
i think depression is a manifestation
as a manifestation can come off of of
all of these
because the depression to me is is uh
uh is a clear manifestation that the
individual has just not
got the spigot turned on enough you know
and not they're not they're not
lightened up enough you know
yeah back here excuse me
non-competitive she says in other words
if you tend to be a person that just has
a hard time
understanding why anybody would want to
compete in anything
the chances are this is not getting
fueled
the uh the warrior spirit
uh enjoys it
kind of kind of gets off on it
procrastination is another example uh
in other words if if you're having
trouble completing things
uh i know nobody here has that problem
but
but if you have trouble if you have
trouble getting projects completed this
would not be getting
fueled what about this one
yes
would would would manipulation come
under lack of fuel for the magician well
i i don't know what do you think
being manipulated might be
and they say allowing oneself to be
manipulated see what would happen is you
would not you would not
be very reflective if this is not being
fueled
you won't think a lot about what's
happening with you and other people
see you won't be this is the archetype
of awareness
you will not be very aware
of what's happening in your environment
you know there are a lot of people who
are surprised when their spouse walks
out
they didn't notice anything wrong see
well that's because this wasn't
receiving any fuel
if this is receiving fuel one is very
aware
of the dynamics of everything and
everybody around
what else would you say
that would be one way see if you didn't
if you don't have this fuel that means
you have to have somebody else
be your magician
well the she says hypochondria
that would be not being able to figure
out what all these physical symptoms
about
that is to say people tend to somaticize
when they're not very aware
psychologically
so that's a very subtle point you see
that
that is you'll find that people who are
not very psychologically aware
whose magician is not getting enough
fuel
they would just have a lot of body
symptoms
nothing's wrong in my life but i just
have all these bodily symptoms
that's what they call in the literature
somatization
and what about a person who's not having
the lover fueled
yes
she says sexual dysfunctions uh like
impotence or fragility absolutely
it's very interesting to work with
people who are who are living their life
as if this was not even
a configuration in their psyche
it's very interesting you know they can
there are many many marriages
that have that make no place at all for
the lover
configuration another it gets no energy
by either part of the couple in fact
they come into therapy and they'll often
say well i just
don't know what's wrong i just uh
i just don't guess i know how to
to be a lover
and the thing that always fascinates me
is when they get an extra marital
relationship going they learn awfully
fast
take a crash course in this
but that's this this is an excellent
point uh uh there's just no energy going
into that
the person is completely tone deaf
about buying flowers they can't buy
flowers
they can't go away for the weekend
they can't get a lock on their bedroom
door
it's just amazing they can't think of
any of those things
any other expressions of of this there
are a lot of expressions of this yeah
how would isolation be an expression of
not having that fuel
in other words if this is being fueled
the person is
enthusiastic about the world
and they're going out to it
uh this is sort if this is if this is
not being fueled by any archetypal
energy
the poet in the person won't be online
see
they won't be they won't be feeling
poetically
about anybody or anything the
the writer in them won't be uh online
you know what else
okay now that's interesting she says she
says bad
choice of uh of a love relationship
or perhaps going after someone that's
already involved in another relationship
it would be an example of that because a
lot of the time if a person
has edible conflicts this is an example
of someone who is very conflicted about
this and they're afraid to put much
energy into this
and what they will do is they'll be so
insecure about this that they will
always arrange to be with people that
won't really challenge them much always
go with quote safe
people married people you know they
think that they won't get a divorce
you know they think that the other
person won't get a divorce
yeah okay you die somebody say boredom
no but that's a wonderful example
boredom that is if you're if your lover
is getting any fuel any archetypal
energy
uh then you're never bored
with it with things things are
exciting to you you you're constantly
interested
in things and uh the world is more like
the garden
see for you i mean it's a delightful
place
uh and you just you just wish you had
four or five more lifetimes so you could
enjoy
everything see uh yes
i i don't know
to me that at least for a given period
of time
people who aren't getting enough of the
type of energy could look
like they're getting too much yeah
[Music]
yeah she says that a lot of the time
um due to the compensatory
dynamics in the psyche of person that's
that's
not getting enough would look like
they're getting too much
uh energy that's right see one of the
things you've got to look at
in this is that
wounds in one's narcissism
can result in either too much
fueling or not enough
and so the pathology will express itself
uh in different forms uh and the goal of
course
uh in in what we've talked about is
as spirituality certainly from a jungian
point of view
is to have contact with these energies
for life
but have contact with them in a way that
fuels and serves life
and doesn't destroy life doesn't
disintegrate the personality doesn't
lead them to have to act out
but enables them to have enough of this
energy
so that life can be full and life can be
joyful
i think we're out of time i want to
thank you and i'll stick around a little
while if you want to discuss this
further thank you very much
thank you thank you